hi everyone i'm kangmu li
i'm going to talk about our recent work
on metaphysical learning which is
learning to forget for meta learning
we know that
the standard supervised learning
paradigm requires a large amount of data
for
each particular task
while future learning
aims to learn a new task
under fuel data regime
in order to achieve business goal
meta learning tackles the problem by
learning prior knowledge shared among
tasks
which is then used to quickly adapt to
each new task with only a few label
examples
but the learning algorithms can be
broadly classified into metric based
model based and optimization based
depending on how prior knowledge is
formulated
and how applied knowledge is used for
the patient to each task
i will focus on the optimization based
method
among optimization-based approaches
a model agnostic meta-learning is short
maml has gained a lot of attention from
diverse domains
for its simplicity and generalized
ability
mml formulates prior knowledge as a
learnable initialization that is shared
across tasks
from the learned initialization
model is fine-tuned to each task
with a fixed number of steps and
learning
rate
to achieve a test
task specific model
however
we questioned
whether the shared and fixed
initialization is the best starting
point for learning diverse tasks
when tasks are different from each other
in several aspects such as difficulty
thus we first analyze
what kind of
problems occur when several tasks share
a learnable initialization during
training
starting from the current values of
initialization
model is fine-tuned to a given task
using support
set the generalization performance of
resulting task specific model is
measured on new query examples of the
given task
which is then used to calculate the
gradient for the initial initialization
such that
generalization on this task is maximized
then
a similar procedure is performed to
calculate the gradient for the
initialization to maximize the
generality generalization to another
task
finally a gradient from several tasks
are gathered to update the
initialization
as you just saw
the good initialization location is
mostly likely
different for each task
thus when the gradients are gathered
from tasks to update initialization
the resulting initialization may not be
desirable
to any of the tasks
if you look at more extreme but possible
case
where gradients from different tasks
point in opposite directions
the gap between the desirable and
resulting initialization location
becomes large
we name
this gap as gradient conflict
through analysis on conflicts
we observe that the degree of conflict
are largely differs among layers
in particular
deeper layers seems to have large degree
of conflict
while shallow layers have a smaller
degree of conflict
this analysis is consistent with
well-known observation from prior work
where they show lower layers learn
general representation
while deeper layers encode
task specific features
we also observe that the degree of
conflict differs among tasks
implying
each task has different degree of
preference of the initialization
upon these observations we propose a
novel
learning to forget scheme called l2f
that forgets a part of initialization
that conflicts with the learning of each
task
this can be done by attenuating
the initialization by gamma here
considering how the degree of conflict
differs among layers
we aim to control the amount of
attenuation or are forgetting for each
layer l
similarly
we also desire to control attenuation
parameters for each task i to this end
we introduce a metal network g pi
that generates task and layer wise
attenuation parameters
gpa is conditioned and layer wise mean
of gradient to obtain a task and layer
wise information
gpa is a simple three layer mlp
with a sigmoid activation function at
the end
to ensure attenuation parameters are
between 0 and 1.
here
we show we show l2f mechanisms in
animation
from the shared initial initialization
we use support examples
to compute
test embedding
in this case
gradient tau i
g py then uses this test embedding to
generate attenuation parameter gamma i
the generated gamma i is then used to
attenuate the initialization setup
after attenuation the fine tuning
process afterwards
is the same as other general
optimization based meta learning
framework
the training of meta network pi i is the
same as the training of initialization
where pi i parameters are updated
such that
generalization on normal query examples
is maximized
in future learning
algorithms are often evaluated on future
classification across domain future
classification and
future regression problems
in standard one-shot and five-shot
classification benchmarks such as mini
image net and tired net
not only l2f greatly improves the
performance of maml
l2f is also shown to improve the sota
method
leo
ltf l2f also demonstrates a substantial
uh performance improvement in
challenging across domain future
classification in this case uh the train
isn't
done on the mini imagenet and the test
is done on the cov data set
it even
if you saw regression regression problem
l-12 greatly improves mml and
outperforms other
baselines
as
many of you know have noticed uh future
learning algorithms are only evaluated
on simple problems
uh to further stress the
uh generalizability and the
effectiveness of our proposed method l2f
we perform experiment on more practical
problems
such as video frame interpolation and
visual tracking
when applying meta learning to video
frame integration ltf is shown to better
adapt to diverse scenes
and show better interpolation research
compared to mal
similarly
when applying meta learning to visual
tracking lgf is shown to greatly
outperform
mml and other baselines
all in all
we introduced the gradient conflict
phenomenon that occurs when sharing
initialization in one of the most widely
used algorithms maml
open analysis
we proposed a learning to forget
framework l2f
that is facilitated by attenuation
we showed that
the proposed method achieved high
performance and
can be applied to diverse domains
the proposed ltf is a flexible program
module
so it can be applied to any
optimization-based method meta-learning
method
okay this work has been uh
worked with uh my student sony veg um
thank you for your attention
hi everyone this is hang from visual
computing group of msi
in this presentation i will talk about
our works on how to adapt virginia and
fine-tuning paradigm for small data
regulation
let me begin with a story about immunity
ignite challenge has played an important
role
in triggering the developing era in
capital vision
in 2012 there is a dependent work named
annex knight which won championship of
that year's challenge
with the error rate reduced by a amazing
compared to the last year's champion
entry
this is a master moment
indicating the coming of a new different
era for communication
however
this is not only only master moment
please look at this illustration
this is a curve indicating the
percentage of papers which include the
word deep in the title
after atlas night if began to be
included in configuration papers
however
we also noticed that
there was a big jump at the year 2014
so
what is this new master moment
let me post the answer
the master movement is caused by a new
paradigm named petrini and fine tuning
unlike in the internet 1000 data set
which has more than one million images
many computer vision tasks
don't have enough data to train a good
deep model from scratch for example
semantician arbitration
and the fine-grained calculation
we call them medium skill problems
in 2014 researchers found that a
pre-training and fine-tuning paradigm
can well address
this dynamic that the deep networks are
forcibly pre-trained on the large
imminent 1000 image calculation task and
are then fine-tuned on the medium-scale
problem
this paradigm significantly increased
the prevalence of dependent approaches
concretely there are two stages
the first stage is to pre-train a bubble
network using large amount of
pre-training data
in the second stage the pre-trained
weights in the pre-training stage are
used to initialize ways of the backbone
network of the dancing task
so
how about this pre-training and
fine-tuning paradigm for regulation of
various small data for example nice than
a thousand examples
there are two related topics about small
data regulation the first one is
semi-surprise knurling
pre-series illustration
in its topic there are
a few label images for example
are two types images are two dot images
there are also large amount
of unlimited images
the goal is to well recognize cats and
dogs
for a long time the protruding and fine
tuning paradigm was certainly invested
probably due to difficulty in getting a
meaningful patreon model
later we were sure that petrinian
fountain paradigm is also powerful for
this problem significantly better than
other methods
the second topic is future learning in
this topic
we have many samples for base classes
and a few examples for level classes
the goal is to transfer knowledge from
base classes to larger classes
the main difficulty lies in the domain
gap between pregnant and fine tuning
later we will assure that the petrinian
fine tuning paradigm needs levitation to
perform well
now let's see how we apply the
protruding and fine-tuning paradigm for
service-worth learning
here is our framework
the adaptations from the standard
virginia and fountain paradigm are
twofold
firstly in the protein stage we use
self-worth progeny instead of suppressed
training
but using self-sufficient protein we can
leverage a large amount of unlabeled
data for training
secondly to have also elapsed training
data for the dancing fine tuning stage
we propose a label propagation approach
by these two adaptations
we release the power of the pre-training
and fine-tuning paradigm for
semester-wise learning appreciate the
right plot
the x-axis shows the number of
neighborhood supports the y-axis shows
the
test top 1 accuracy
our approach is absolutely
27 percent higher than the previous best
approaches
in the following slides i will introduce
these two kit designs
the first key design is self-source
programming
in science department learning although
we can leverage the small amount of
labor data for model training
its performance is poor due to two field
driven signals
our proposal is to leverage huge
unlabeled data for pre-training
so can self-sustaining perform good
enough for model programming
our answer is yes we tried two methods
the fourth method is named canonization
the input is a grid image another task
is to convert this grid image to a color
image
the second method is named instance
discrimination
this method trades each single image as
a class
and training the model by an instance
calculation task
the second key design
is a additional label propagation step
to enrich labeled images for fine tuning
firstly we build a similarity graph
between naval data and enabled data
using the similarity between their
pre-trained features
secondly we propagate existing labels
from the left to the right and all right
images will be assigned to the labels
which are used in the following fine
tuning stage
we conduct
a ablation study for these 2k designs
the green curve shows the results of
training from scratch the blue curve
shows the results by using self-worth
versioning it has absolutely
15 percent improvements when the number
of labeled images is as small as 500.
the writer curve shows the results by
further using a label propagation step
we obtain another about absolutely 20
improvements when the number of label
images is as small as 100.
it also performs strong and imagine that
another 1000 data site with one percent
label images for each category the top
five accuracy is improved by more than
absolutely
35 35
next we adapt the pre-training and
fine-tuning paradigm for fusion learning
while they're helping a lot of existing
methods for visual learning a paper on
sar 2019
demonstrated like the progeny and fine
tuning paradigm performance very
competitive as shown in this table
since then the patronian phantom method
becomes mainstream for future learning
however does battlefield training
results in better future accuracy
we studied this problem by using margin
in progeny in general positive margin
will improve the programming performance
for example in its illustration using a
0.2 margin value can make different
classes
distribute more distant from each other
this is a experiment using more margin
values increase the margin values can
help improve the discrimination in the
power and base classes as shown by the
right curve however
they will harm net power and larger
classes as shown by the blue curve
as shown on the right figure
the one-shot and function accuracies are
both improved by about four points under
three points respectively
on three benchmarks of future learning
we all achieve significant improvements
over previous best approaches about five
point points are minimized by two points
and cube and about seven points are
minimized to cube
here is a summary of the talk we try to
adapt the pre-training and fine-tuning
paradigm for regulation of very small
data
we first adapt this problem for services
learning
where there is no enough label data to
train a good model our solution is to
leverage safe source learning which is
powerful
we then adapt this paradigm for future
learning
where there are domain gaps between
progeny and fine tuning we find that
lactic margins matter in positioning
this is the end of my talk thank you for
your listening
hi everyone my name is joe i'm a
principal researcher at microsoft today
i'm very happy to introduce our recent
work on how much can gbt3 benefit future
artificial reasoning
as we all know now large-scale language
model pre-training has become a central
uh training paradigm for nlp
parameter accounts are frequently
measured in billions rather than
millions for example the openai gpt3
they have
175 billion parameters
an interesting phenomena is that when
the language model is scaled up it
really can demonstrate various junk fuel
shot performance so that is a without
any parameter update when you only feed
a few in context examples and then the
model can adapt the new task very
quickly so as you can see in this plot
on the popular super glue benchmark
for language understanding the gpt3
model by openai can demonstrate very
strong
fusion performance
um so since gpts3 is a language model by
itself so it can naturally benefit um
so pure nlp problem but then how about
the multimodal taskers so the question
that we are going to ask in this talk is
can gpt3 also benefit visual reasoning
task and we are going to use the weekly
task of to illustrate
the visual reasoning so basically given
an input image and a question and an ai
system need to predict the answer
so
specifically i'm going to
talk about a very challenging vqa
benchmark called weak okay weak way so
in this benchmark the model needs to use
external knowledge not in the image in
order to
correctly answer the question
if you can see
the example here
given the input image if you ask a
question what sort of vehicle uses this
item the model needs to first recognize
what's the item inside the image and
then to retrieve the knowledge to solve
the task
previous methods basically use a
two-step approach
they will first perform knowledge
retrieval and then perform knowledge
reasoning
so basically all these methods they will
use explicit and structure the knowledge
bases such as concept.net and also the
wikipedia
however this can be problematic
first the retrieved knowledge might be
very noisy and irrelevant to the
question second the re-embodied
knowledge features during reasoning
might be very different from the
original meaning in the knowledge source
so
in this talk i'm going to introduce pika
which is short for
prompting gpt h3 while the use of img
captions
so the key idea here is that we are
going to use the precent gpt3 as an
implicit and
unstructure the knowledge base
so
this is a very simple approach but very
surprisingly we find only using
foreshoots just using four training
examples this can outperform supplies
the sultan
using the whole training data set
then
um how do we achieve this
um since gpt3 cannot understand the
image right so it's a pure language
model uh so we uh translate images into
textual descriptions specifically uh
image captions or image attacks that
gpt3 can understand then we will create
this kind of uh prompt
so includes the prompt head and a few in
context examples and then the frozen
gpd3 model will just produce the answer
in an open ended text generation manner
so so even just this very simple
approach can already surpass the solder
performance but then how can we better
enhance the performance we have two
strategies
for one we design a young context the
example selection so basically we are
not going to use a random example but we
try to select better examples based on
some metrics such as the question and
the image similarity
with the input text example
so as you can see here given the input
image and
so the question is when was this type of
translation invented
if we do not do a in context example
selection the prompt
constructed prompt can be kind of noisy
right but then when you use the question
and the input image as the uh
as the tool to select a better context
examples
the constructed prompt is much closer to
the input test example and we believe
this will benefit
the future performance
the second approach is the multi-query
example basically we want to merge
predictions from multiple queries with
different examples it's a kind of doing
and symbol
um
so now i want to discuss briefly about
our so uh so results the sorta approach
basically using all kinds of knowledge
sources wikipedia concept now google uh
images they only have
sub-optimal performance and here our
pickup base without using uh in context
selection and multi-variant symbol
already surpassed the sultan and the
piccard r4 can further boost the
performance and we also find that both
captions and the tags are useful for
gbt3 primping
um you may also curious how many shoots
are enough
uh here we show uh photoshoots can
already
be sold out and then
typically if you use more
in context examples this will lead to
better performance and finally uh
frozen is another very recent method by
deepmind that also performs multimodal
full shot learning and our pica can
outperform frozen by a significant
margin
then why
why gpd3 are so powerful on okwa we
believe there are at least two reasons
first is the gpt3 model they have
encoded a very rich factual knowledge
so if you say the first two example
given basically the same question when
was this type of transportation invented
actually it's a very challenging
question right because you need to
predict the exact year this
transportation was invented but gpd3 can
do this due to the rich factual
knowledge encoded
this is in another case
where can you get this and then
the gpd3 encodes common sense knowledge
and the no
the answer should be glossary store
since the contacts
include the shopping cart and the
bananas
we can also let gt3 to just generate
answer uh the rationales so basically we
add in another pump this is because and
then let the model to generate the uh
the answer uh the rationales by
by itself
um so so interestingly for example still
the example i used just now this is
because glossary store is the most
common place to get food so kind of gp3
also knows how to
produce the right answer
so i'm going to
quickly summarize the work here is
we
are the first one to study how to use
gpt3 for multimodal taskers and with
very few in context examples gbd3 can
surpass the surface the soda by
a very significant margin
but then you may also wonder what's the
limitation here indeed there are many uh
several obvious limitations
uh so basically it's uh due to we
convert images into captions so this
will uh lost important visual
information and in order to verify this
we test the pillar on weekly week 2
with questions on very detailed visual
contents and as we can see from the
results indeed the performance are
lagging behind the surprise the sota
though
so it is still better than the frozen
method
so kind of to let you have a better
sense of how it works uh
so for example for the cases uh gpt's
gpt3 can work
so due to
the gpt3 has encoded the knowledge and
due to the generated image captions uh
so it's very related to your question
and it can be some reasonable guess here
but then for some thriller cases
indeed for example here when you ask how
many giraffes are there there are so
this will be very challenging for the
model to predict due to you just do not
have the detailed visual information
but just a simple caption so uh so
looking back
so so i think microsoft has been a very
important player in the virgin language
preaching space there are many exciting
works has been produced such as united
oscar vila vimvil and so on but then
really looking forward when can we have
the gp3 moment for the vlp model and
then this is our future direction
so uh by the end i'd like to thank the
collaborators and thank you for your
time